und trotzdem glaube ich dass es auch
noch mal wichtig ist klar zu machen dass
wir als deutschland glaube ich auch
schon eine verantwortung tragen
menschenwürdige verhältnisse zu
gewährleisten weltweit das problem
beginnt aber natürlich ganz wo anders
und ich würde sagen nicht nur auf europa
ebene sondern ganz global also wie
verhindern wir überhaupt dass menschen
sich auf den weg machen und wie schaffen
wir legale wege dass mütter frauen und
kinder überhaupt die möglichkeit
bekommen sich auf den weg zu machen
wie schaffen wir aber auch legale
möglichkeiten für menschen die sagen ich
möchte auch über ein arbeitseinkommen
sozusagen mich verbessern integrieren
all das sind ja offene fragen all das
sind offene flanken und deswegen
produzieren wir diese bilder auf den
gefährlichen mittelmeer routen menschen
die wie gesagt die mes entkommen sind
und dann dort zu tode kommen also wir
hatten ja jetzt gerade auch diesen
gedenktag an alanco die beispielsweise
und trotzdem ist es wichtig und ist
sozusagen auch makaber dass ich das
ansprechen muss als kind von
flüchtlingen meine eltern haben sich
auch eins auf den weg gemacht vor 50
jahren und ich bin sehr dankbar dafür
weil wir unterdrückt worden sind da wo
wir herkommen und das zeigt aber auch
die gemengen lage das ist kompliziert
ist ob die politisch verfolgt wird ob du
sozusagen kriegsflüchtlingen bist ob es
akut ist und das sind natürlich alles
dinge die da mit hinein fließen und
trotzdem glaube ich dass die
integrationsfähigkeit in unserem land
begrenzt ist und dass wir es nicht
schaffen alle aufzunehmen und das kann
auch nicht unsere aufgabe sein sondern
wir müssen alle sozusagen mitnehmen und
wir müssen natürlich wenn wir wenn du
jetzt sagst dass die griechen dass wir
die erziehen müssen ich glaube die
würden sich dagegen verwehren wenn ich
es ihm darum die griechen meinen wir ja
auch im stich gelassen die sie klar auch
beschäftigt auch mit der türkei
beispielsweise um eine herausforderung
um den mittelmeerraum als krise
[Musik]